the young in and often contentious
debate two-thirds of Venezuela's
opposition lawmakers voted to end the
interim government of Juan guaido
demanded for more than three years has
stride and failed to house president
Nicolas Maduro
Juan Guido had declared himself the
legitimate president of Venezuela after
calling maduro's 2018 re-election Hashem
and amid large protests against the
government
the United States and dozens of other
Western Nations backed him and issued
sanctions against maduro's government
but Madura remains firmly empowered
despite a worsening economic political
and humanitarian crisis in the country
in a last call to save the institution
on Thursday white dog proposed to
maintain the interim government calling
on the National Assembly to instead
appoint a new president
it's a call to Common Sense let's defend
institutionality the Constitution and
unity above names or personal interests
but the three other political parties
moved on with their decision to end the
parallel government some lawmakers
voiced their opposition fearing it could
put the country's foreign economic
assets Chief among them U.S based oil
refinery Citgo currently controlled by
their interim government back into
maduro's hand this is shameful I cannot
understand how we are committing this
suicide the end of Guido's government
coincides with a slight Improvement in
Venezuela's economy and a new
geopolitical situation that has
strengthened maduro's position
and the Biden Administration is
considering an easing of sanctions in
exchange for free presidential elections
in 2024 which are being negotiated in
Mexico
in a way it's a return to reality the
opposition is admitting Maduro is
effectively who holds power and now they
will have to find a different Democratic
solution to get him out of power while
Friday's vote once again revealed the
divisions affecting Venezuela's
opposition it was likely time for a
change of strategy now the opposition
will focus on finding a unifying
candidate for the 2024 presidential
elections hoping that Venezuela's
economic vows and the negotiations in
Mexico will push Maduro to allow for
free and fair conditions for them
Alessandra Al Jazeera Bogota